from the earliest time you can remember
you wanted to be on saturday night live
yeah i used to i used to like make
videos of myself walking out of the
bathroom and going like bobby morning
her
and like doing the dawn part over yeah
like i used to film
fake sketches like on like a huge video
camera like when i was a kid like what
was it like the first time you heard don
pardo actually say
your name i burst into tears did you
yeah because it was your life
because it was crazy well yeah i'm i'm
very fanboyish and i'm very
into that whole the history of it and
all that stuff and
every day you walk in there and you hear
that music playing on a saturday it's
like
i can't i can't believe featuring bobby
moynihan
so the audition did you get any laughs
from lauren i
i i feel like i did yeah i think i was
told to also like they're not gonna
laugh like no one's gonna laugh
great but i had a weird thing i
auditioned twice like the first time i
auditioned was on the snl stage and it
was like there was a table and it's kind
of in the darkness and there's
one single light on lauren and you can
see him and you know he's there
oh my god an audience of one well in my
mind you know what i mean like
there was a spotlight on just him was it
just impressions
a couple characters and a couple
impressions i think i did nathan lane
i think i did what was that like it was
the dumbest
joke in the world and i'm almost
embarrassed of it i just said that it
was nathan lane for the hamburger
society and i sang some
that he was in funny thing happened on
the way to the forum i heard
something peculiar something and i was
like it's something for everyone eat a
hamburger tonight and that was it it was
the dumbest joke in the world
lauren wasn't laughing uh i think he was
laughing at like i can't believe you
just did that
but i think i think that was also part
of what got me the show was like i'm not
the best impressionist in the world but
i'm i'm willing to go out there and take
risks idiot this story goes
that you auditioned once and then all of
a sudden
you don't get the call or you did it was
very vague like i
i i i have a definite recollection of
him
saying the phrase like well maybe we'll
start you in january
and i probably pissed your pants well i
did and then i was like
so are you are you saying i have the job
and you're trying to figure out when
you're gonna hire like when i'm starting
or are you saying like i didn't know
what was happening
right and at that time i had very long
hair and a big beard yeah when i
auditioned and
he was like why don't you cut your hair
and shave your beard and you know come
back and we'll see
what's under there essentially see
what's doing
yeah but i went home and almost
immediately the writers strike happened
so you don't hear anything i was sitting
at home going
i think my life's dream just came true
but i have no idea and there's no way i
can ask or find out
and i just literally just sat there like
in limbo waiting
14 months yeah and then uh oh my god
when the writer strike ended i
the phone rang and it was snl and i was
like i think this is it
yeah and then they called me up and they
said maya rudolph had a baby during the
writer's strike so we have to hire a
girl
oh my god poor you i mean that was the
worst
that i was like it's over that's it and
then i got a call on like a monday that
seth and bill hader were doing this uh
web series
and they asked me to be in it and i was
like oh this is my consolation prize
like they're just being nice
and i went in and did that and it was
just a couple days of doing this thing
and i was like well at least they were
really
nice like the next day seth called me up
it was like a monday and was like why
don't you come in and audition on
wednesday i had to come up with all new
material in two days
you mean you had nothing nothing and
this one in particular like
i was like they know me and they know
what i've done
so i'm just gonna try and go in there
and show them like not bobby's audition
but show them like hey this is kind of
the dumb stuff that i find funny
yeah like on the subway there
uh somebody there was a guy and he came
on and called somebody an asshat and i
thought i'd never heard that term before
so i just improvised a bit where i was a
guy
a guy selling um something called ass
hats that were just tiny hats
like i i literally was just improvising
you're kidding me i got a picture i was
like i'll do snaggle puss
from like i said for one of my first
impressions i was like this is a snaggle
puss from hannah barbara and i was just
like
heavens to murga troy and like it's the
dumbest thing ever i was like they'll
never put this on the show but like
at least they'll be like this guy's nuts
maybe we should keep it around and i
ended up doing snaggle pose on the show
which is ridiculous
evans to mergatroid i wasn't talking
about me
when you do snooki what do they spray
paint you yeah airbrushed
you would have to do it in three minutes
during a commercial break and then i
would be in the scene afterwards and i
would have orange knuckles and like
orange in my ears
that's still the fun aspect of saturday
live right the fact that it's live
it's the craziest feeling in the world
yeah i remember one sketch where
you know sometimes you'll be in the
middle of a show and they're like this
is cut we're doing something else
and you have literally 47 seconds to
change into a completely different
outfit and i had to change into a suit
with a beard and a turban it's crazy
when you watch the sketch the wall is
still coming up in the background
right yeah and i remember i remember
sitting down and thinking like this is
what it's like to be on snl
and then the second it ended i went to
go change my suit
and inside the pants on the suit it said
jay belushi and i was just like that's
the craziest thing in the world